changement de méthode la semaine
dernière les autorités turques ont
modifié leur façon de compter les
infections quotidienne désormais tous
les nouveaux cas positifs sont
comptabilisés et plus seulement le
nombre de patients traités pour des
symptômes
résultat plus de 30 mille nouvelles
contaminations par jour la réaction des
autorités n'a pas tardé pendant la
semaine
tous les jours un couvre-feu général
sera mis en place
de 21h à 5h cette restriction se
poursuivra sans interruption
le week end de 21h le vendredi soir à
cinq heures le lundi matin le
gouvernement est aujourd'hui confronté
au dilemme de contenir l'épidémie tout
en continuant de préserver l'économie
menacée de récession
les nouvelles mesures ont commencé à
être appliquée dès ce mardi
les personnes de plus de 65 ans et de
moins de 20 ans ne pourront pas utiliser
les transports en commun les prières
funéraires auront lieu avec au plus 30
personnes y compris des parents immédiat
et les mariages ne pourront pas dépasser
ce nombre des doutes subsistent quant à
l'ampleur réelle de la pandémie dans le
pays
l'association des médecins de turquie
est convaincu que le nombre de cas
quotidiens
à l'heure actuelle représente le double
du bilan officiel
une situation qui fait désormais de la
turquie l'un des états les plus touchés
d'europe